the idea of genetic engineering is
something that we associate with with
the 20th century we didn't even know
that genes were actually the mechanism
of heredity until the middle of the 20th
century and the direct modification of
genes for some purpose really didn't
even start happening until the 1970s but
it's worth noting that human beings have
been in some ways influencing the
genetics of organisms for a very very
very long time for example in nature you
have things that look like this we call
them wolves but today in our lives we
also have things that look like this now
these dogs did not come about naturally
they came about from many generations of
breeding of human beings taking things
that started off looking like wolves or
foxes and selecting for certain traits
they might have selected for traits that
maybe they're small and they look more
like puppies even where they're
full-grown or traits that they are more
docile they're more likely to listen to
what a human being says to do or traits
that they're good at killing rodents or
whatever else it might be and over time
repeated selection of those traits led
to what we see as these different breeds
of dogs so even though human beings were
doing this for hundreds and thousands of
years they were influencing what DNA
gets passed on from one generation to
another they didn't know about the
actual genetic code but it was a form of
genetic manipulation nonetheless
similarly if you look into the plant
kingdom when you go to the store and you
see that sweet apple things like that
might not have existed in the form that
you see them today it is very likely in
fact most agricultural products people
might have found wild apples and we
could be talking thousands of years ago
they might have found wild apple trees
let me draw a quick apple tree here and
they might have found that the apples
were a little bit sour and small and
hard to eat and hard to digest but over
time people selected the
jeez that had sweeter apples that had
larger apples and made the conditions so
that they were more likely to reproduce
so over time you got larger and sweeter
apples like the type that you see at
your store and as I mentioned most
agricultural products that we have today
are the result of hundreds or thousands
of years of this type of breeding so
even though that might not be the formal
definition of genetic engineering which
typically is referring to something like
gene modification which we've only been
able to do in the last few decades human
beings have been doing some type of
influence on organisms DNA for a very
very long time
but with that said in the last few
decades we've we've been able to become
much much more precise with influencing
DNA through genetic engineering in other
videos we'll go more detail about how
that is done but you have this idea of
recombinant DNA combin int DNA where you
could take genes from one organism and
put them in another organism and you
might say why is this useful well let's
say that there's a tree you want to grow
let's say it's an apple tree but it's
very susceptible to a certain type of
disease and if that disease hits you
lose all of your crop but what if you
could insert into the DNA of that apple
tree maybe a gene that makes it more
resistant to that disease and this is
what people actually do today so they
will insert insert DNA and it could be
some from pretty wild things I've read
stories about insert inserting insect
DNA into a plant so that it will be more
robust in some way or another
now this idea of recombinant DNA and
genetically modifying food this is often
known as a genetically modified organism
this is somewhat controversial many
people say hey this is good it allows us
to produce more robust foods in fact
part of this recombinant DNA inserting
DNA into something else it might make it
more nutritious it might provide for
more vitamins but other people would
argue that hey we don't know exactly
what all the repercussions of what we're
doing will happen we might think it's
helpful
but when you're taking what DNA from one
organism and putting it into another how
does that affect the nutrition or the
long lasting effects of eating that over
time so this is something for you to
think about and we're starting to go
when we start asking these questions
into the field of bioethics as we have
more and more control over the genome
and especially as we'll see the human
genome there's questions that we have to
ask about is it good or is it bad but
going back to this idea of genetic
engineering and recombinant DNA other
things that you could do is you could
let's say that we need to produce
insulin for diabetics well maybe you can
take a bacterial cell and insert into
the bacterial cell the gene that helps
produce for insulin and then all of a
sudden that bacterial cell can become a
human insulin producing factory so that
we could have more insulin for diabetics
that this insulin could then be
harvested that is a use of recombinant
DNA and so we really are going into an
interesting period in humanity for many
thousands of years we were breeding
things but now we're learning to
manipulate things at a very fine grain
level and it makes us ask all sorts of
questions there are likely to be some
very good things we can do produce new
medicines produce more robust crops but
there are also questions about what are
the side effects and the bioethics get
really interesting when we start
thinking about modifying the human
genome itself because when you're
modifying genetics you're not just
modifying one organism you're modifying
all of their offspring you're modifying
the genes that exist in the gene pool
and so some very good arguments for
modifying the human genome are
correcting diseases some things that
could be very serious but over time
things might people might say hey I want
to be a little bit taller or I want a
certain hair color I want straighter
teeth or they might say I want a child
who has this trait or that trait so
things get very very interesting the
more we think about how genetic
engineering may be used